watching you'll see
someday I'll be
[Music]
congratulations thank you I mean insane
you guys are all insane in this when I
think of The Little Mermaid I think of
that iconic sound
ah what was it like for you performing
that like I would love to know Hallie
like the nerves behind it the
conversations you were having about that
specific sound how many takes you did
yeah it was very surreal for me to be
able to film specifically that Melody
line that's been so iconic to so many of
us for so long I was really excited to
kind of make it my own but also honor
the work that Jody Benson did who was
just incredible and just happy to be a
part of it honestly how many like takes
did you do and were you nervous at all
like going in I think it was quite a few
take no it wasn't it was like one it was
it was none I remember you basically I
swear you didn't like that
it was perfect straight away I don't
remember
yeah yeah I think it was something like
that were you nervous like were you
practicing it at home and is that like
the moment where you were like oh my God
I'm playing The Little Mermaid oh yeah
that was a big staple I felt like I had
big shoes to fill with especially the
music of the film is so beautiful and I
just wanted to do that Justice yeah yeah
well you definitely did
um and of course she makes that sound
you know to give up her voice and a lot
of The Little Mermaids and Ariel's
acting is silent like a lot of what you
have to do is silent did you work with a
movement coach at all like how did you
convey emotion through your body and
what was that like for you guys yeah
well we had amazing uh a team of
choreographers Tara and Joey or just
absolutely amazing and they helped us a
lot when it came to things like that
um and then just with my facials I had
to really find the deeper meaning of
what Ariel was feeling in those certain
moments and and what it would feel like
to no longer have this voice but have
this desperate longing still for this
future for this person so it was it was
a lot to navigate and uh happy to do it
yeah did you Channel or like what were
you thinking of as you were like doing
certain things like did you rely on
something like a mantra that you were
saying to yourself as you were silent
yeah I think I just really tried my best
to put myself in Ariel's mindset and put
myself in the mindset of being away from
everything I knew and suddenly thrown
into this new world and what that would
feel like how scary how exciting how
everything would feel so I I just tried
to play that and obviously like the
chemistry between Ariel and Prince Eric
is just like the most delicious out of
any Disney animated couple as you guys
know how what did you guys do offset to
sort of build that chemistry and really
bring that to life in the live action
yeah I mean I think it happened pretty
quickly I think Hallie was the first
time I met her was at the at the screen
test she was so kind to me very
supportive and then from the first day
of rehearsals it was easy I mean we
became friends really quickly and I
think what's nice about this version is
that we really I think feel that
friendship on screen I think it's
something really deep of course the
romance is there but I think they find
each other funny and they teach each
other things and I think we brought a
lot of the stuff that we share off
screen uh into the into the film nice
did you guys get a chance to like hang
and sort of bond set before like
shooting at all or oh yeah oh yeah
definitely it was it was so much fun to
be able to have kind of like a partner
in crime to do this with because this
was so new for me I had never done
anything like this and the fact that me
and Jonah were both taking on such
bigger roles than we have ever done was
really like a bonding experience on its
own so we would talk about a lot before
try to figure out our best ways to do it
put our best performance forward and
just having that friendship I think
really helped us both and I tried to
show you around London a bit so yeah I'm
doing for females and stuff so yeah
on screen like it's so delicate and So
Graceful and I'm like I'm sure it was
like that
like did you guys get any kiss do's and
don'ts we I can't remember we didn't
we didn't withhold anything either they
really wanted they didn't tell us
anything they were like okay just go
right yeah although I remember one quite
funny thing which is that it was during
covid and at the time we still don't
really know exactly what was going on
with it and how to deal with it and so
there was a lot of uh separation a lot
of the time you had to be quite careful
obviously for a kissing scene we
couldn't do that I remember they came
and gave us like Listerine mouthwash
yeah do you remember as if that was
going to kill the covert just in case
just in case we were going to pass it to
each other through that either that they
thought I had bad breath
yeah I mean I was gonna say I didn't get
anywhere I'm just joking
I saw you then
[Laughter]
sorry to ask you Holly about the dingle
hopper because it's my favorite thing
ever what is it like for you to like
look at Forks now like did she like play
with the fork before coming to set you
know like what is that experience like
for you now yeah I love looking at four
clubs
what it's kind of weird that you can't
look at them the same way my mum said
this last night having seen it she we
went back and she was like looking at
this I was like mum what are you
doing it's just a fork I relax
it changes the way you see forks for
sure you can't live in that world unless
you become a human yourself is that even
possible oh that's what I live for
Melissa McCarthy like I walked out of
that theater and I was like Melissa
McCarthy Melissa McCarthy Melissa
McCarthy as Ursula congratulations wow
like you stayed true to the character
but you made it your own there's a line
that you say when Ariel gets her legs
and she swims to the surface that I like
almost peed my pants talk to me about
like
infusing your humor and ad-libbing like
did you do any of that did you come up
with that line a little the little
stupid little feet yeah that I threw in
I just thought it was funny and the guys
like Rob and John thought it was funny
so we kept it and I was like see pretty
snarky of her and she's like kind of
drowning to throw a jab at her but it
felt it felt dishy and right there's
like a couple things but everything else
was really in the recipe and and I just
like followed along delightfully but it
was so fun oh my God you could tell how
much fun you're having did that just
come to you in the moment or were you
thinking like stupid little feet like no
I think I think it was in a rehearsal
where we were singing it and we were
recording it for me to like kind of
practice with and I think I I threw it
in there and it made John laugh so I was
like maybe I'll keep saying that
it's so good the scene of Poor
Unfortunate Souls I like fist pumped
after seeing it last night I was like oh
my goodness just the animation like
everything came together so well what
was it like shooting that underwater and
what I wanted to know Melissa like were
you wearing tentacles were you sitting
were you standing are you in front of a
green screen it none of it was
underwater I was never in water got it
but it was just amazing that they
digitized the hair and we were always in
these kind of all different rigs if you
were swimming one way it was in one kind
of rig where you were like horizontal
and and you moved along with like seven
people kind of pushing you in like a
giant baby stroller of sorts and then if
you're spinning it was one or if I was
up in wires on another if I had to be
flipping but we just kind of did it they
they're so masterful John and Rob with
what they do and the choreographers and
the stunts and the dancers we just took
a little little section by little
section so when I'm sliding down
something we're flipping over or you're
going into the abyss it's we're we're
all doing it for the most part there's
very you know there's little times where
of course I can't crawl across the wall
I'm not really an octopus then that
would take over and they would be my
tentacles but it was while I had eight
dancers with huge tentacles that as I
moved moved with me it was wild you had
eight dancers as your tentacle holding
tentacles
so everyone could kind of feel and like
if Triton was up higher like they would
have Javier up higher and we were like
they wanted us to feel the space it was
really amazing well you both are so
incredible in it I mean Javier is King
Triton I I was just thinking about how
you have to have such a certain type of
build to play like King Triton and I was
like did you train for that like
physically or anything yes just the arms
because
one of the things I said to Robin Jones
don't don't make me go back how do you
say very trusted yes
I'm 52.
I'm not rapid
or you work a lot the Italian then you
put like a good six-pack and they said
no that's way too expensive we put an
armor so you just did you actually
that's so funny get to eat whatever you
want and then you're just like yeah
that's amazing one thing I really love
about these Disney movies in general I
don't know if you guys had to do this
but for most of these movies you have to
audition with a song that's not a Disney
song and you have to Disney buy it did
you guys have to do that at all no you
didn't have to do that I would never get
the job
at all what was your audition process
like then I went after trying
desperately to get a meeting with Rob
and I was like I don't I'm perfectly
fine I know he's going to say no but I
knew that if I didn't try I would regret
it forever because I'm sure I was
nowhere even toward the bottom of his
list I I'm sure I was like why would he
be thinking of me for this I'm not a
singer and he very nicely agreed to meet
me we had a great lunch and I think we
really kind of had the same feeling
about how to play her and talk about
kind of her loneliness and all of those
things so delightfully for some reason I
conned him into it
so you really thought that you were like
at the bottom of the list no I didn't
think it was on the list and I don't
think I was I just don't think I'm in
like that category for to do a song like
that and because I associated with a
musician will get this are you so proud
of yourself like how did you feel after
watching that scene last night at the
premiere I am proud of myself because I
was really nervous about it and so to go
through with that I was glad that I was
like I'm 52 as well uh that's why we're
brother we are twins yes
um that we can you know that I can still
push myself and be like it's okay do
something scary it's fine Javier I know
for you I was reading that you described
this as like a very Shakespearean role
and for me Little Mermaid meant so much
it was the first movie I ever saw in
theaters and I'm very close to my father
and so I got really teary-eyed at the
end of the film because to me at the
core this is a father-daughter story
um what was your daughter's reaction to
you playing games she hasn't seen it yet
so I can wait for her to see it and now
my my son my 12 year old boy I'm my 10
year old girl it's gonna be a big moment
for me does she know that you're playing
King trading does she knows that she was
in the rehearsals back in the day when
he was before the pandemic and then
after the pandemic and while shooting uh
visits were not allowed to go on set
because of the of the coming rules so
she hasn't seen anything it's gonna be a
big Revelation to see that wow did she
say anything to you when she was there
with you well the first time she heard I
was going to be in the movie she asked
me if I was going to play Ariel
which I want to see that movie really
bad
I really do
I'm all for that come on dizzy come on
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs
you idiot
can we talk about the fact that like the
animals and creatures in Disney movies
are just like the unsung heroes like who
would Mulan be without Mushu or like
Hercules without Pegasus it's like these
characters rely on flounder and Scuttle
and Sebastian to really like hype them
up in moments of Doubt so if you guys
could ad-lib lines for people
experiencing doubt or maybe nervous to
go in for that kiss what would you say
to them
oh
I don't know that was such a hard pivot
um
I was like you're right there but what
um I would say you know what just you
you have no I mean like look at you you
have nothing else to lose I don't I
don't know who I'm talking about we're
ad living so it's like I'm assuming that
someone needs to go in for I'm just like
you know what are you doing what else
are you doing you know like taking a
shot and you'll know
yeah yeah I guess it depends on who
we're talking to it would just be like
anyone and you know as like a Disney
sort of that ancillary character you
know that's like the hype man like well
in my character the thing about flounder
is that he I know I would tell people
you know it's important to take risks
but also like my character flounder he's
not really a risky risk averse yeah he's
a hypochondriac yeah
yeah I don't know I mean Sebastian wrote
a whole song about it he's like pretty
pretty Versed and just kissed the girl
like because the girl was so funny you
guys did such a good job on that and
just the music and the little mermaid's
so good what was your reaction to you
guys seeing your like your voices coming
out of these creatures on screen like
the first time you saw your character on
screen for me it was it was weird
especially because I I believe I was 12
or I just turned 13 at the time of of
filming
um so I could kind of hear myself but at
the same time you know that feeling of
you know hearing yourself you know it's
always a weird feeling
um kind of wasn't as much there just
because I couldn't really recognize my
own voice that much just because it
changed quite a bit or at least I like
to think that it changed yeah yeah what
about for you guys what was your first
reaction seeing your voice come out of a
bird and a crab on screen I mean so cool
so I mean literally so cool as as with
any time like you're you kind of see
yourself but especially as as Scuttle I
mean you're reintroduced to a whole new
character in your life in general so and
you're a part of it so it's very cool
yeah I I do a lot of Animation work but
this one was special so like it was nice
that it was like a a vocal Choice like
so a lot of times you do animation
people are like you know really want you
to be as natural and as close to
yourself as possible but like we got to
spend enough time with these characters
that we really got to develop voices for
them and that for me was super fun to
watch that to get to like it was easier
for me to be like that's Sebastian not
me right and I know that you actually
put so much
you have for any other role in your life
you went to Trinidad you went to Jamaica
lin-manuel Miranda's son is named
Sebastian and you were playing Sebastian
so no pressure yeah I wanted to know
like how do you how does David Diggs
feel about crabs like do you eat crabs
do you like crabs delicious what is the
experience when you look at a crab now
oh still delicious mostly but I I was
just um I was in Mexico and I was
walking on a beach and there were a
bunch of little like hermit crabs there
sort of like running across the beach
and uh that was this was like pretty
recently like after we had sort of
started thinking about the film coming
out I remember seeing them and just
being like Oh yeah watching the move
it's sideways and be like oh man I felt
like a deeper kinship to them but I'm
still I still eat crabs that's so
beautiful yeah yeah I thought of deep
connection too but then and then I just
like I ate a whole crab yeah yeah when a
bird came along I know right there it is
your rap scene was like so good and she
Jacob I wanted to ask you because you
voiced Luca and Pixar so you went from
being like a sea monster to like a fish
yeah I'm devolving I guess yeah
what do you think Luca would say to
Ariel if they ever oh that's really I
mean I guess they do have quite a bit in
common since they both want to kind of
experience the
the I guess the human world that's
that's a really good question though I
think that he would probably just um
share some words of encouragement I
guess you know to follow her dreams I
guess and I'm sure they'd be good
friends obviously yeah I admit that in
the past I've been a nasty
weren't kidding when they called me well
a witch but you'll find that nowadays
I've learned it all my ways repentance
is Alan Menken on behalf of like every
90s child that had a little mermaid
comforter I just want to thank you for
creating the soundtrack to our childhood
you're welcome and I know there's a
rumor out there of like Walt Disney
being frozen or something and I'm like
is that is that the plan for Alan Menken
like what's the Disney Insurance
you must be protected at all
well the music will live forever and
you'll need me for that
Pocahontas Aladdin what do you consider
to be your magnum opus maybe Hunchback
why Hunchback well Hunchback is just the
most emotionally complex and adult in
the issues that it deals with plus it's
the most sophisticated in terms of
pulling on classical
you know romantic classical themes and
the Liturgy of the church and all but
they're also different mermaid is is so
innocent and so almost naive in its
Simplicity and it's just disarming for
people and then when you get to Beauty
it has more texture more again it's a
little more classical and closer to uh
some of the early Walt in terms of those
colors when you get to uh to a Latin
Aladdin is really draws on a spoof of
the Hollywood view of the mysterious
East and so we pull on those kind of
colors in Harlem Jazz and all those
influences that I think that made it
much more fun than if I've just been you
know literal Pocahontas is probably the
most literal of the scores
hunchback
has a literalness to it but it pulls on
so many things the Liturgy of the church
the Gypsy Romany the Romantic classical
music all of those elements in there
because he gets a Hercules Hercules is
pure gospel and so all of those
different Enchanted was the most fun
spoof of all the different Disney Styles
telling the story of this animated
engineer who thrown into our world and
you know all the stuff that ensues from
that and then Tangled is kind of almost
folk rock in a way like and um so they
all have their own places
so it's hard for me to really and then
of course there's Home on the Range the
Classic Home on the Range which was you
know a lot of country music and it's
it's remarkable how you're able to dip
in all those genres and I love that
Hunchback was the first thing that came
to your mind because it is very
grandiose in that way like
it's crazy
[Music]
wow and then we get to Grace
yeah
but what's interesting Alan is you you
juxtapose it with the Simplicity of
Little Mermaid and how this was the
first film that you had ever composed
and it's almost like the mo the more
simple the harder right when I think of
Little Mermaid I think of
ah like tell me about creating that
moment
the the water flowing right
straight into the sea
and also yes her voice
and then of course look at this stuff is
and there you're getting a normal
teenage girl going look at something
that needs when you think my
collection's complete and you think I'm
the girl that combination is just
you know I mean Howard was such an
amazing collaborator
um so all of those colors you get and
the decisions to have have Sebastian be
a Caribbean crab as opposed to a stuffy
English crab was huge so thus you have
the
that kind of very rhythmic to see meat
is always greener and
and you want to take you're taking
advantage of the characters also that
both the stiffness and Romanticism of
Sebastian the court composer so he's got
that
he wants to be respected he wants to be
uh serious but he's also so endearing
and all these influences dictated the
score more than anything else you know
little Little Mermaid really was our
follow-up to The Little Shop of Horrors
I know I remember you went from there
and then you did film but it's it's I'm
just so enamored hearing you
hearing you pontificate on where you
pull the influences from like their
personality right you're like
Sebastian's endearing so then you make
that sound so you make this masterpiece
it's it and now we have a live action
yeah when you get the call that they're
doing a live action does that make you
nervous are you like oh my god this is
my masterpiece tell me about infusing
rap into this version of The Little
Mermaid and what those conversations
were like that was just a matter of me I
created a actually a Caribbean piece of
music but not uh
I can't even play it for you but a
little bit Caribbean piece of music
that's underneath and I thought Lynn
would send those lyrics and he went off
and he wrapped over them and it was like
oh my God incredible it was just
Serendipity
um but that's you know you're playing
you're not playing tag but you're kind
of
um going back and forth between two
collaborators
um I had something he had something I we
you know we react to each other I mean
Lynn working with you is such an outer
body experience for him because your
music and the Little Mermaid literally
set him on the trajectory to be who he
is like I was talking to Stephanie
Beatrice from Encanto and she was
telling me that he uses a Little Mermaid
as a shorthand he's like this is your
Ursula moment as creatives for you and
Lynn I think people often think when
you're creative you have good ideas all
the time and that's not true uh what
space do you create where are you
recording what is the setting where you
let creativity flow through you well
anywhere I go but I have a studio
Upstate New York and Lynn comes up and I
worked with me there
um first we had meetings at Rob's
apartment and we dissected you know the
the new book the new treatment where the
songs would go and then where the new
songs might go
and we discussed each of the song
Moments we knew we wanted something for
for Prince Eric
to sing both about the girl but also
about this his love affair with the c
and this uncharted waters that he wanted
to explore the Uncharted part of his
life and of course her life too
um and then the you know for the first
time when she's finally on land
I gave him a piece of music it was very
little thing
it was actually a variation of something
that's in the first movie
[Music]
can we do a two against a three
so you have that rhythmic rub that was
very much the result of this particular
collaboration I wish I could
be
[Music]
foreign
I thought about you and people like you
um when I was making it well it means so
much to people people grew up on this
film you know I'll say to someone you
know they'll say what are you doing so
I'm I'm directing The Little Mermaid
home that's my favorite you know when I
was a kid or that's my favorite you know
my my child's favorite or my whatever I
mean it's it says everybody has a deep
connection to it in some way I think it
was because it was the one that being
watched over and over and over again you
know this is the first movie I saw in
movie theater wow yeah and getting to
spend seven minutes with Alan Menken I
was like this is what seven minutes wow
but let's talk about you because you are
a demand of the hour you have directed
so many things Mary Poppins Chicago
Pirates of the Caribbean and you said
that this was the most challenging thing
you've ever done because no one's ever
shot a musical underwater no it was
crazy what was it like shooting those
underwater scenes I was I was reading
that the actors were on wires and things
called like tuning forks and
teeter-totters and I was hoping you
could like paint that picture I love
that you know about that already that's
exactly what you know what we did is
exactly what you were saying I mean the
crazy thing was we had to design it all
in advance because we can't just walk in
and say well we're just gonna do this it
I had to communicate the shot and how
and what we wanted the actors to do to
the camera team but also to the stunt
Team every every
um actor had like eight or nine people
moving them around so they would
literally because they were you know
they'd be on these Big Crane arms and
they and and it had to be timed to music
had to be time to
um dialogue that kind of thing and it
was
sometimes you know I would call Action
they would be on some kind of apparatus
and then I would say cut after two lines
and we put them on a different like rig
like now you have to be on wires to do
this move so it was all done in these
pieces and the only way we were able to
do it was literally in rehearsals we did
it on our feet first and found the scene
so you could play the scene and know
what the scene was before we put
everybody up in the air
but the crazy thing is you know after we
did it all I mean they're wearing wig
caps and because all of the hair is
added digitally the costumes most of the
time they're just wearing like a suit
with tracking marks and so everything is
added afterwards it's all designed in
advance but it's all added afterwards
the water the backgrounds of the fish
the you know everything all of it and um
but I have to say that
the most important thing when I was
working in the film do not let the
technical aspect of this movie lead it
it has to be about story it has to be
about character it has to be about
acting you have to feel for these people
so you care about them otherwise why why
do it you know wow the way you were just
describing that I was just picturing
eight people around each actor Melissa
was telling me that eight people were
her tentacles yes they were bugs bugs be
like burglary it is I love that you know
that who that is of course I watch it
all the time
exactly right did you feel like you were
doing that and I also read I've so many
questions that um under the sea was the
hardest and challenging and I wanted to
know why it was well uh with Under the
Sea The the heart the reason was the
hardest because it's a it's the big
production number of the piece but
there's one live actor so how do you do
that so I I actually
um took a page out of the Playbook of
Walt Disney he had worked with the
ballet Roost when he created Fantasia a
ballet company because he needed the
animators to work with some kind of form
to sketch something so I brought I
thought that's a brilliant idea and I
brought the Alvin Ailey Foundation over
to London to work with them to create
this number and so they were replicating
all these sea creatures and so the
animators this rcgi animators had their
bodies to work from and we had chosen
all of the creatures in advance so you
know here you're playing Olympic and
here you're playing a feather starfish
and they would try and recreate their
moves and and and so that we could use
those moves and to give to the artists
so they could sketch it because I had to
design we had to design with John DeLuca
and our choreographers we had to design
a massive production number and it was
it was I mean it was it was the most
insane thing we've ever done but it was
yeah that's why I'm most proud of that
for sure I'm proud of you you should be
proud of yourself that's so
the gospel singers in Hercules yes yes
and how they had all their dancers come
in and the animators like you know went
off that are you gonna can you release
this footage to me
there's a feature just on under the sea
and how we built it so you'll absolutely
see that it's really cool I mean how I
part of me last night actually wanted to
sort of just one runs one like run for
everybody one scene so they could see
what we actually filmed before
everything was added okay well if you
need anyone to come
the best part of Little Mermaid for me
is was is the Easter eggs you know
seeing Mickey and Donald and Goofy at
King Triton's concert in the animated
version of Mr Limpet like that was so
cool oh I love that talk to me about
putting Easter eggs in this film and and
what fans can look out for well there
were little bits and pieces I mean we
had some on the set because John Meyer
our production designer is a massive
Disney fan so like for instance on the I
mean I I have to actually look and see
if you can see it in the film it was
definitely on the set like there was
there was a rope that was like on on the
ship that was literally like Mickey a
Mickey
like you're like literally a rope like
that so I I I have to actually examine
and see if there's if but it was all
there on the set I mean I guess the our
biggest kind of I don't know Easter egg
is probably
the I mean I guess I'll say it you know
the original Ariel Jody Benson you know
has a cameo and that was because listen
she's an old friend I mean I directed
her in the 90s wow early 90s and she um
she's just so great you know she's just
such a warm wonderful beautiful person
and uh and so supportive so that was
exciting to have her and and no one was
more excited than than Hallie she was
out of her mind